so wrote this article back in 2017 about
leaving 90 comments the concept of a
dollar 80 is leave your two cents you
know that's saying well if you do it 90
times a day to good posts on Instagram
you'll build awareness through the
comments we've seen through the years
over the last six years that Tick Tock
comments is like a culture in itself and
now we have threads right and a lot of
opportunity for growth a lot of
opportunity for threat influencers and
things of that nature and new people
creating new opportunities for new
relationships and new awareness and so
the dollar 80 strategy is a monster
opportunity right now on threads if you
committed to growing on threads and you
go around and find a hundred posts a day
and meaningfully leave a comment to 90
of them that is a huge opportunity for
people that have the time and the
bandwidth so I'm going to link this full
article which is detailed in my
Instagram profile and other social media
profiles so you can click it read it and
attack threads